[Music]
let's start with a quick poll
who here is single
that's a shocking amount given that i'm
in a room full of really smart
and very attractive people
we have all seen rom-coms like pretty
woman
these movies have one message
that one for you is out there and faith
will help you find them
really
i love love
love to me is the most powerful drug in
the world
love feels like magic
love drives some of us a little bit
insane
but let's be real
in order to find love we need to be
strategic
and strategy is my thing
i am the definition of a career woman
when i was 12 years old i started
working as a carpenter
i made 12 dollars an hour and i felt
tremendous
from there on i was hooked i worked my
way up in the construction industry
leading multi-million dollar projects
and my life was only about career
money was
freedom then one sunny afternoon i land
in berlin excited to get back to work
when life decided to throw me a
curveball
i had a missed call from my obgyn and
when i called back i learned that my pap
smear had come back positive
at age 25 i was diagnosed with cervical
cancer
when i called the doctor back she asked
me a simple question
sarah do you want to have children
if not they would do a one-time surgery
that removes the cancer forever
if yes they had to do a small surgery
with a 20 risk after cancer coming back
confronting this a strong independent
career woman in her mid-20s felt
impossible
i fell into a hall of self-reflection
i had money
but i might never have family
was there more out there in life than
just career
the good news is that i hold a phd in
data science and engineering and
therefore i decided to not rely on fade
when it comes to figure out that
question
so in very much me fashion i went all in
in that year i did real-life experiments
and i ended up going on a hundred dates
with a hundred people yeah it was a lot
of work
four years and two serious long and
happy relationships later i have two
empirical learnings that i'm going to
share with you today
first
input equals output
yes we have all heard this it's done for
business school but it's also very much
true when it comes to dating
dating is a part-time job
however since we're little children we
spend 40 plus hours a week advancing our
careers learning from generations of
generations who have done this before
and everything in order to make more
money
however enough research shows that if
you want to live a long happy and
fulfilled life it's not really about how
much money you make it's all about
relationships
so why do we not focus on what matters
most to us why do we not learn about it
if i had to rewrite my standard essay
now about what matters most to me and
why
i would probably write about love
and let's be real i would probably not
be here today with you
second big learning
a long-term partner is way more like a
business partner and a best friend than
somebody we have a spark with
and don't get me wrong i love the spark
spark is great however i'm arguing to
look behind the spark and figure out if
long-term interests and values actually
align instead of just relying on an
initial chemical connection
when i had my two empirical learnings
given that i'm a scientist i decided
maybe there's real research out there so
i went down a rabbit hole of reading
every research paper that has ever been
written about dating and love and i put
it all together into something that i
call an informal phd in dating
so i ended up writing a dating book
called start up your love life where i
apply business knowledge and data
analysis on finding a life partner
and yes you can buy it now on amazon
i brought some of the most important
insights here with me today for you
but first let's take a step back we were
talking about julia roberts and richard
gere they meet each other randomly and
fall deeply in love
what a great story but how likely is
that
the odds of finding love randomly are
one to five hundred sixty-two
zero point seventeen percent
it is five times more likely that your
next bottle of wine is going to cork
we spend an average about a tens on the
time we spend on choosing the right
career on choosing the right partner
and from going to dates to actually
having a baby it takes an average seven
years in the u.s
so how can we make the odds a little bit
more likely and how can we make this
whole process a little bit more
efficient
we need to use business knowledge
and yes weird business goals so let's do
that
when you start a new business the first
thing you should think about is do your
research and development and decide what
market you're going after in business
terms we call this total addressable
market short term
so let's do this for me as a dating
product
my tam is as false i'm looking for a man
50 of the market
age 30 to 37
6 feet or taller only nine percent of
the market
with a bachelor's degree
and you know similarly attractive
and max 50 miles from here
the tam for me as a dating product is
223 man
that's not big
if i'm willing to go down to 5 11 or
taller my time goes up to 450 men
still not big
but doable
after you do
your research and development and decide
on your time the next step in every
startup process is to decide on your
sales strategy
the good thing is when it comes to
dating there's only three big sales
strategies that captured ninety percent
of the market
you can date in bars and restaurants
you can date on dating apps or you can
date through friends of friends
and every good investor in the room will
have the same question for me right now
sarah what's the return of investment of
all of that
the return of investment also roi for
these three sales strategies is as
follows
if you date in bars and restaurants the
ri is you need to meet about 90 people
to get one actual match
the ari of dating apps is you need to
match with 60 people to get one real
potential candidate
and the ri of dating through friends of
friends is about 30 people to one
yes you're smart enough we should all
date through friends of friends
after you have figured out your sales
strategies the next step in your startup
process is you need to do some piloting
and figure out if you have product
market fit
and product market fit in dating is
really when you found somebody you
hopefully like but also where you don't
have any serious deal breakup with
so in order to get there you need to
decide on your deal breakers versus your
nice to haves
write those deal breakers down screen
for them early and do not compromise
because you probably get hurt down the
road
and yes i know of some people who keep
track of the deal breakers in excel
spreadsheets so they have weekly kpis
next step in your dating journey
is marketing and the good news is when
it comes to dating marketing is really
all about optimizing your dating profile
and there's a lot of research about this
first
when you take pictures for your dating
profile take them from the left of your
face not from the right
why because throughout art history we
have developed an inherent bias towards
seeing beautiful faces from the left
and not from the right
thanks to people like leonardo da vinci
second if you're a guy and you think
sunglasses or whatever kind of other
glasses will do the trick get rid of
them you lose 15 percent of swipes
and yes if you have a picture of you
from that last wedding or what about a
picture with formalwear put it on your
dating profile because you'll score
higher on trustworthiness and influence
and yes you need a picture with a pet
preferably dog
so go out there steal your neighbor's
dog take a picture with it and put it on
your dating profile because you'll score
higher on dateability
and lastly if you're a man wear bright
colors and if you're a woman we're red
and you're gonna crush it
i'm telling you all of this to give you
hope there is research out there that we
can leverage to make dating more
efficient and ultimately more enjoyable
business is not magic
business is strategy
love is not magic either
it's more like a magic trick
so look behind the curtain figure out
what's actually going on and treat it
more like your career than like
something that will randomly happen to
you
make magic happen
after having research dating for several
years i have the toolkit the scientific
formula for love and the conviction to
build a real family while having a
career
luckily
i'm now cancer-free
and i can still have children
have i found the right partner yet
no
not yet
i might have to rethink some of my deal
breakers and my tam
but i know that by putting in the work
and using strategy i will find a
co-founder for my life so that we can
ipo our love
and given last week's kpis and funnel
data i think i'm slowly getting there
so instead of waiting for richard gear
to drive by in his limo go make strategy
or co-pilot get into the driver's seat
yourself
and start up your love life
[Applause]
[Music]
you